then let me ask you
do you think supreme court justice
sotomayor falsely claiming a hundred
thousand children are in serious
condition from covid was her being dumb
or evil that's she didn't just say that
let me let me let me add some things to
here too she also claimed that covet
debts are at an all-time high they have
been going down since september
according to the official data look it
up yourself she also said that omnicron
is deadlier than delta obviously no
scientific findings presenting that as
well so so i i think i
i don't know dumb or evil
a combination of both well
because if you put yourself if you put
yourself in a position of power and
you're and you're dumb and you're ruling
over people's existences you should
learn to shut the hell up right so if
you're dumb and you know you're dumb and
you're still dictating how people should
live you're dumb and evil you're a
combination of both i don't i don't see
dumb here i see ignorant and i think
there's a distinction to be made there i
think that she could gen because like
you read the actual quotes that she said
and i'm just like this sounds like an
aunt of mine that just you know just
overdoses on blue pills and just watches
you know corporate press i mean she
sounds like a woman that is genuinely
uninformed and ignorant about what she's
talking about otherwise she wouldn't say
that stuff because to malevolently say
this that doesn't really add up not as a
supreme court justice yeah yeah
you'd be strung up for doing that yeah
i'm trying to mislead the american
public it sounds like what whoopi
goldberg was saying too that any new
variety any new variant of a virus is
more powerful which is blatantly not
true because you can have a variant of a
virus that's less powerful than before
she said deadlier i missed that quote
more powerful she said more powerful and
it was like whoopi
you're a passionate person that believes
the things you say so so make sure you
you know what you're well what you're
saying is right before you sorry i
thought you were talking about sonia no
i apologize i made it maybe i made a
mistake maybe maybe she's she's going
off of the the dragon ball z principle
where goku was very powerful then gohan
was stronger than goku at least in the
cell likely that explains everything i
understand your train of thought
um
she was triple
whippy was triple vaxxed and got coveted
so she's like what is going on but then
she kind of slipped back into this
brainwashing variety variants are always
more powerful and the only way to stop
it is that well she said i did
everything i was told to do
why am i sick and that's a lot of
questions that a lot of people are
having especially in some of the most
vaccinated places all around the world
and there's a lot of serious questions
to ask there because there's a lot of
consequences that we can't even get into
but people will make up their own minds
not a medical doctor not here trying to
give you any kind of medical advice but
there's a lot of questions that are not
being answered by the medical
professionals that should absolutely
concern that every citizen let's bring
it back to the supreme court they're
listening to oral arguments on the
vaccine mandate and either
these these liberal justices have no
idea what's going on
or they're deliberately misleading the
american people i'm going to call
ignorance and that's why i brought up
whoopi because she seemed very ignorant
like definitely not malicious what she
was saying she didn't know what she's
saying this is the person deciding if
we're going to have a vaccine mandate
this is the person controlling your life
and existence in the next few coming
weeks and months who's going to this
year
exactly so this is this is the person
that's going to decide if you get to
live your life freely or if the
government's going to come in a way and
force a medication on you so do you
think that it's evil just because
they're making a decision because she's
in a position of power and i think you
know obviously with all the news reports
coming out right now i think she's going
to understand that she was definitely
wrong here
these people are evil
that's that's the conclusion here but
but if i it truly is just ignorance just
someone being a dumbass i think they're
going to realize sooner or later that
hey
hey you know someone near her is going
to say you were wrong about everything
clarence thomas asked
is the vaccine the only treatment for
covid and that a lot of people are just
like that's a question wow that's a very
important thing because when it comes to
vaccine mandates the argument is osha
should have the ability to do this and
then a very simple question not for or
against just a clarifying question is
there is there anything else we can do
that's why i was shining on twitter and
yeah yeah just a simple question is
there anything else we can do i'm not
saying yes or no to the mandate clan
thomas has a really really powerful
question and this this question actually
leads you to another line of questioning
um i can't remember who mentioned this
but they said
you know what about all the other
diseases huh why is it just coven um i
can't remember who brought it up but
they were like what about the flu yes
and
they said oh but you know the flu
no there's no there's no answer so i
tweeted we should mandate everyone be
forced to get every vaccination that's
available in the united states i believe
the cdc lists 58 why not if one night
why not all
clearly something doesn't make sense
when they're trying to mandate one and
not all because people do die from these
other other other illnesses
they have you can't have it both ways
so in the hospital they would require
people to get the flu vaccine or you
would have to wear a mask for the entire
flu season some nurses would refuse to
get the flu vaccine sometimes the flu
vaccine was not very effective because
it would go based off of australia's
virus and try to find a way to counter
the american virus as well didn't always
work very well i'm guessing that we're
going to end up seeing the same effect
with cobit but i'm curious that they're
going to make it for everyone or if
they're just going to well
luke you were saying that there's like
they're saying now that omicron may be
like the final variant or something well
there's a lot of medical professionals
uh whether it's in many european
countries there's also a lot of medical
professionals coming from south africa
right now saying that omnicron will be
the final variant the end of this
pandemic this is something that i was
talking about the possibility of a few
weeks ago and there is some early
preliminary data suggesting that because
this virus is so transmissive and
because it's so less lethal than the
previous one for many of uh the category
groups here that it will run through the
population in a span of one month to
three months and therefore give everyone
natural immunity and therefore end the
pandemic from here and there's a very uh
small small chance it's extremely
unlikely that there's going to be a new
variant that's going to be more lethal
because of how
this variant is already taken over all
the other variants that's some of the
early data early information i was i was
talking about it for a while now
look what's happening right now in south
africa it gives us a lot of reason to be
hopeful
regarding your question from earlier to
tim about why don't we vaccinate for all
the vaccines at once there's this thing
called compounding that affects
compounding activities with um any kind
of medication so you can test you have
five different medications you test one
of them on someone you test the second
one on someone test third but you don't
know what they're going to do when
they're test put in at the same time so
that's a completely unique test you need
to do and for every new drug that's
added to the mix that's another
completely new test and you got to see
how that interacts with people well if
bioshock bioshock taught us anything
it's that people become splicers and
they'll slowly go crazier and develop
superpowers there's also this report you
guys have you guys do you guys know
bioshock
[Laughter]
you won't become a splicer part of the
way they're getting into jugs of video
game reference
there's also some reported um accounts
saying that there was a conversation
between justice kagan that asked what
risk do the unvaccinated workers pose to
others and uh you know i haven't
verified this myself but according to
some of the early statements we're
seeing here osha's own data shows that
it's unclear to exactly what extent uh
that question could be even answered if
this procedure even reduces transmission
this is not me saying it this is some of
the transcripts happening from look at
this look at this yahoo news justice
sotomayor claims not to understand the
distinction between between state and
federal powers
this is insane let's talk about a recall
powers for a minute wow dude i need the
context of this
supreme court justice sonia sotomayor
professed not to be able to understand
the distinction between federal
authority and state police powers during
oral arguments in a consolidated case
before the court on friday morning
critics including plaintiffs submit the
rule represents federal and bureaucratic
overreach quote i'm not sure i
understand the distinction why the
states would have the power to institute
a mandate such as osha's but the federal
government wouldn't stated the associate
justice
if um
we have to give a lesson on the ninth
and tenth amendment to our own supreme
court justices yo when i say the system
is collapsing y'all can't tell me i'm
wrong you can't have them in power for
40 years what is going on dude
it's idiocy it's idiocracy it's like
you've got a politician the secretary of
agriculture and they're like why would
you put water on plants yeah it's like
dude if you're in charge of it look at
pete buddha judge it is idiocracy the
the
he's a small town mayor they put him in
charge of transportation and then he
goes missing for several weeks
it's it is it is i'm sorry mike judge's
timeline of 500 years or whatever was
wrong it was like 10 years 10 years and
we found ourselves here come on donald
trump is in the wwe hall of fame he was
president mike you're a prophet but you
got your timeline way too far out it was
way sooner here we are i heard he's
doing another beefs on butthead yes yeah
i'm really excited about i'm excited
about that totally but michael he was i
mean idiocracy is becoming more of a
documentary by the day
especially with leaders like kamala
harris especially with just the
absurdity that we're seeing on the
corporate media and i think there's a
deliberate effort to dumb down the
average human being and let's let's be
real about something okay you guys have
all seen idiocracy i imagine yeah yeah
camacho was not a bad dude no he
recognized that uh luke wilson's
character was the smartest guy he brings
him in
and by hiring the right guy solved the
problem by getting the brondo off the
crops actually could have called the
movie meritocracy well they they first
put him in jail for being no no camacho
didn't camacho the president actually
got him out and was like let's do this
and so i got to say he may have been a
wwe hall of famer as the president he
may not have been the smartest guy but
he made some good moves that ultimately
benefited his country and donald trump
may not have been the greatest guy he
may have been a wwe hall of famer he may
not have been the smartest guy but he
did some policies that were really
helping out
look at that idiocracy come true um i'm
afraid that there's forces that are
attempting to shatter our government
and uh i don't know we do you think term
limits getting you guys think about like
these people out of here uh supreme
court justice congressman is gonna help
uh no
this whole entire system is absolutely
crooked it's absolutely rotten to its
core and it's it and it's only it only
profits off of people's ignorance and
this is why i think there's the
deliberate effort to dumb people down
and to normalize this kind of videocracy
that we have been seeing instituted
almost every step of the way with
mainline establishment culture mainline
establishment politics mainline
establishment society it all
incentivizes you being a dumb cod of the
machine going along with of course the
bull crap that it spews was there a
period in american history where you
liked the american government where you
thought it was functioning
you're you're asking me if i like
government all right
that's that's that's a question that i
think is very self-evident i don't like
any kind of you know government or
authority or centralization or or top
down control of people's free existences
and and that to me is just yeah again my
perspective my personality uh because if
you look at the us government especially
from its you know onset there's a lot to
to criticize there especially with its
imperialistic kind of endeavors
especially with its foreign policy
there's a lot of things that of course
you could criticize uh but there's also
a lot of things that you could
complement with especially the united
states at least representing the ideas
of free speech of being able to defend
yourself and even though it's not
perfect i think it's one of the free
best places in the world
right now standing up against this
global tyranny and i think that's why
there has been such a concerted effort
trying to bring it down destroyed from
the inside because it still represents
this bastion of freedom that is standing
in the way from total totalitarianism
total totalitarianism and technocratic
overlords controlling every uh existence
uh every every part of our existence
that we have
but don't you want to be in the pod yeah
yeah
you know what's funny is that literally
everything they're presenting to us is
the matrix like in the pod eating bugs
you will be you'll be hooked into a pod
plugged into the metaverse yo they're
literally describing the matrix yeah
they're like join the matrix you'll like
it the new york post ran an article
highlighting how some cows were given
virtual reality so they could at least
feel like they're outside
my tagline was like this is going to be
your future you're the cow yeah this is
what they're doing this is literally
what they're doing they're creating a
digital heroine which they're calling
the metaverse that they're going to have
you licked in through through your elon
musk microchip and there's going to be
no understanding of what is real and
what is not when they control every
aspect of your consciousness
you're going to be literally uploading
your consciousness to mark zuckerberg's
private
playland and when you're in that
metaverse the the ability for them to
subjugate you is absolutely astounding
and i think that's why they're going
forward with this kind of larger
metaverse plan this larger virtual
reality and when they develop artificial
intelligence um especially with the
advancements that they had with quantum
computing game's over for for humanity
are you guys going to plug into the
metaverse 100 yeah i'm already in yeah
i'm on something called decentraland
uh it's it's pretty addictive it's crazy
is it it's a virtual reality yeah it's
basically like a giant chatroom that you
walk around in and can interact with
with like are you using kiosks no i was
just on the mouse and keyboard because
we like the oculus is super cheap and so
we've got it and that space pirate game
is so much fun it's amazing that's how
they get you though man like you you get
this like laser sword and a shield and
you're like swatting robots and then you
can switch to the gun and you're
shooting lasers at the robots it's a fun
game and they've also got in the oculus
this virtual chat world where i don't
remember what it's called but you can
pick your avatar you can be any kind of
weird you can be a carrot you know i
bring it up because i saw a guy walking
around he was a kid and i'm like this
guy really wanted to be that my guy was
like a generic looking guy i guess i
don't know i don't know
but you walk around and i guess i don't
know if this is the way it's set up but
my understanding is that as you talk
when you walk closer to people you get
louder in their headset and when you
walk away is that how it works something
like that yeah that's cool although i
didn't i had the sound off when i was in
decentralized what mystical made-up
creature are you in the meta version
are you a hippie
yeah yeah yeah also they have cryptos
that they tie to these websites so
decentraland has one called mana and
basically they're prepping for a future
where you use a cryptocurrency as the
in-game currency and it's gonna be you
play to earn and they're gonna have two
six-year-olds and eight-year-olds in
there for 10 hours 12 hours a day like
basically new age slave labor and we're
gonna have to build laws to protect kids
against dude mark zuckerberg is gonna be
your boss like he's gonna be your
president overlord yeah supreme overlord
of your consciousness check it out check
it out look where we already are people
are building businesses in the digital
landscape i knew a guy who he sold some
product i remember what he sold but he
was completely dependent on the google
algorithm that when people searched for
something in his area google would show
him first the algorithm changed one day
and it knocked him down several several
spots and his business stopped all of a
sudden he couldn't get he couldn't get
any sales and he was worried
people build businesses on youtube
youtube bans you because you don't have
the right politics you lose your money
you're excised from society imagine what
the metaverse is going to be like what's
that you've broken one of the rules
because you said a naughty word mark
zuckerberg removes you completely from
the metaverse and now you can't make
money at all or you'll see not even that
not even that your brain chip
wrong thing he's committing a a crime of
thinking something against the
establishment take him down take him out
he's thinking about he's thinking about
doing something unsavory we're gonna
move his kiosk to a further location
away from central land and then you're
like oh what have i done and you're
waiting for like 24 hours for your
ticker to go down so you can get moved
back to your regular spot no you'll be
back but then you think another thing
and you get banned for seven days you
can't even be in the digital cool live
they want you in there still they don't
want you to leave so they're gonna like
punish you but try and keep you in
you're going to be in the digital ghetto
for just thinking the wrong thought
you know you know what they'll do
they'll do we talked about i talked
about this we're doing brainstorming
sessions on how to deal with like people
who post awful trash on the internet
that's legal but you know because
obviously if someone's posting illegal
imagery or illegal illegal content
threats and stuff you you you ban them
but if someone's posting stuff that's
like obscene we were like you create an
underbelly uh if they violate the rule
so many times they just get sent to an
area where people can post whatever they
want right because like we're not going
to australia yeah like australia we're
not going to ban australia we want you
to be able to use the service and
communicate with people but you clearly
you know want to post things that people
don't want to see
like i think in the metaverse if you
break the rules enough they'll just send
you to another dimension yeah a prison
cell change the dimension to a prison
version of the world and you'll be in a
server with a really low income no one
in there can buy your product like
they're all poor people who can barely
afford your product and you will just
all of a sudden be poor in the metaverse
you will be happy chris will be happy
what's your uh uh vr uh representation
what are you going to go as as
nothing i am so analog i was born in
rural kentucky you know
i
mark zuckerberg comes here with a vr
headset and a firearm saying listen you
got to pick uh a person an alternate
reality and a different personality
right now put on the headset where are
you
gun to my head i'm going to go with my
spirit animal the beaver okay yeah i'll
be a beaver what actually happens is
mark zuckerberg walks in and he's like
uh you guys have to put on these
headsets and if you don't i've got a gun
and everyone put them on now and then
we're like all right mark calm down we
all put him up hey mark and then mark
pulls out his laptop and he's like you
actually don't get to choose in the
metaverse i'm gonna turn luke into a
giant rabbit and i'm gonna make ian the
carrot and then you guys are like no
what's happening to us
luke looks at his hands and he's like
i'm a rabbit now
and mark is just in control
my my character would probably just be
like a wireframe guy
you know like that's cool hey the
furries they're going to be the first
ones on this there you go i'm pretty
sure there are no no you don't you go go
in there it's like people who have
identity issues are like going in there
and they're doing this for these for
these reasons i'll bet there could be a
conspiracy even
when we get to the point where your
neural link chip and think about how
crazy this could be you you get the
neuro link installed and now metaverse
is actually you in a digital world where
you can touch and feel and sense things
and they can they can inflict pain on
you they can be like oh you're being
punished press a button and you go ah it
hurts like they can actually hit your
brain
they can they they can do freak they can
make pain friction right so it's a very
low grade pain if you start walking
towards a boundary it slowly starts
hurting and you're like oh and you stop
and back off they can do screwed up
stuff to you once they get inside your
brain man linda what's your character my
character is going to be myself or mark
zuckerberg that's my plan that's who i
want to go over
how do you know mark how do you know
you're you oh my gosh philosophical
questions that's what i would do i don't
know um i really one day there's a virus
and like everyone turns into trump and
they're running around i don't know i'm
orange what am i like all of the trump
supporters would be laughing and
high-fiving each other and all the left
would be like
then mark would be like today there was
a problem where everyone turned into
trump and we're really sorry we're
working to get it fixed but just hang
tight and beat trump for a few hours and
we'll get it sorted you can't log out
you're in the pod people are banging on
that
feels like
they can't okay i'm in i like it i like
it now
i believe that we really shouldn't have
anyone in control of this thing kind of
like a network like a phone network or
roads like no one owns the roads in the
united states it's just kind of a system
that everyone uses that where
the roads go there are some private
roads there's international spanish
companies that literally are putting
tolls on american roads but there should
be politicians selling the the rights
that's messed up but there should be a
freeway of of uh of metaverse i think
that everyone can kind of use it will
our taxes
keep it up keep it going keep it
transparent no because the absolutely
not there's a lot of value to augmented
reality that the speed that you can
navigate through information is valuable
you know adaptability
they're going to have metaverse prison
like there's this movie i watched i
forgot it's called where they invent
this nanotechnology that they put in
your eye and then it creates memories in
your mind and so what they do is they
they want to make it so that if
someone's got a five year prison term
they just sit you down put an eyedropper
in your eye and then it implants five
years of prison into your brain
and so you're like in your mind in
prison and there's no people and it's
like solitary basically how was the
black mirror episode was it a black
mirror episode i think so yeah yeah sure
yeah i remember this lady was like in
this little tiny white box and it feels
like a million years she's being
punished maybe yeah it's like was that
black mirror again thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive
segments on our website where we are
unrestricted in what we talk about so
you'll definitely not want to miss it
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
next time
you